confrontations between these people
as a grandmother that I am I need to know the
name of my granddaughter if she is alive or already
dead why because I don't know anything about
that only we are what we
want we want justice and we want you to
give us the name of each of
our  relatives
have not told us anything We are
here waiting we do not know What happened
inside we do not know anything not good my
part I do not know if my cousin is alive and my
sister too I do not know I do not know
anything
[Music]
without a doubt what happened today in this
unfortunate moment is the product of a
direct attack by organized crime
against the actions they
are deliberately carrying out against organized crime